You know, usually when we talk about a medical diagnosis,
there's this expectation of just absolute precision.
Oh, sure.
Like it feels like engineering or something.
You break your arm, you get an X-ray,
and it shows that, you know,
that jagged white line on the radius bone.
Right, it's binary, it's incredibly clean.
Exactly, the doctor just points to the screen
and says, there it is, broken.
And we like that.
I mean, inherently we find it comforting
when things are visible and perfectly categorized.
We wanna know exactly what we're fighting.
Yeah, but then, and this is why we're here today,
you step into the world of human behavior.
You walk into a clinical psychology clinic
and suddenly that X-ray machine is,
well, it's entirely useless.
Completely useless.
The diagnostic landscape is honestly incredibly murky.
So, welcome to today's deep dive.
If you're a learner, and I know you are
because you're sitting here with us right now,
you've probably wondered how professionals
actually make sense of the human mind without that X-ray.
It's a huge challenge.
Right, so today we are cracking open
what is basically a masterclass in reading human behavior.
We've got this stack of clinical test prep transcripts,
specifically pass-ready prep by Keek,
which are designed for mental health counselors.
Yeah, and the goal here isn't to study for an exam,
obviously. No, definitely not.
We're trying to decode how professionals
actually distinguish between these near-identical
psychological states.
How do they keep people safe?
What actually drives human behavior?
It really is a fascinating framework to look at.
And I have to say, seeing you set up there
for this deep dive,
I mean, you've got this expansive,
warmly lit library backdrop.
Oh, thanks.
Yeah, with those intricate behavioral charts behind you,
it's very fitting because the truth is,
this entire diagnostic manual we're exploring today,
it's ultimately about drawing boundaries.
New boundaries, yeah.
Right, it's an attempt to figure out
where normal human distress ends,
you know, and a clinical disorder actually begins.
And that requires an incredible amount of precision
to navigate that gray area.
Okay, let's untack this.
I wanna start with the most common internal experiences
that, well, pretty much all of us recognize, right?
Anxiety and depression.
The big two.
Yeah.
When I first looked at this source material,
I just assumed anxiety was anxiety,
like you feel nervous, your heart beats fast,
you sweat, but professionals actually map this out
by looking for a specific target, right?
Like the target of the fear.
Exactly.
The anxiety family is entirely driven by fear,
that is the biological engine running the whole thing.
Right.
But you cannot diagnose the specific disorder
just by looking at the physical panic.
The diagnosis entirely depends
on what that fear is pointed at.
You really have to find the invisible target.
Okay, let me try to map this out based on what I read.
So if the worry is just spread out
across a million different domains,
like I'm worried about my job, my health,
whether I left the stove on, my kids' grades.
Just a constant hum.
Yeah, this persistent hum that lasts for months,
that's generalized anxiety disorder.
Well, GED.
But what if the fear is pointed
at something really specific,
like being around a crowd of people?
Yeah.
Well, this is where the clinician
has to dig a little deeper,
because just saying fear of crowds
isn't enough information.
You have to ask, why are you afraid of the crime?
Ah, okay.
Right, so if your fear is pointed at being judged
like at the scrutiny or the potential
for negative evaluation by those people,
then you're looking at social anxiety disorder.
Okay, but what if it's not about being judged?
What if you just feel trapped in that crowd?
Then you're likely looking at agoraphobia.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, in that case, the fear is pointed
at being trapped in a situation where,
you know, escape is physically difficult,
or where help might be totally unavailable
if you start to panic.
So the behavior is the same,
but the reason is different.
Exactly.
A person with social anxiety
and a person with agoraphobia
might both avoid going to a crowded shopping mall.
So the presenting behavior looks totally identical,
but the underlying motive,
the engine of that avoidance is completely different.
So anxiety is basically a smoke alarm.
I like that.
Yeah, so generalized anxiety
is when the alarm is just constantly humming
in the background for absolutely everything.
Social anxiety is when it only blares
because it detects other people judging you.
Yes, and to finish that analogy,
panic disorder is when you are actually
terrified of the alarm itself.
Wait, really?
Terrified of the alarm.
Exactly.
In panic disorder,
the fear is pointed at the next unexpected surge of panic.
So you're afraid of being afraid?
Basically, yeah.
The person becomes hyper-focused
on their own physiological sensations.
So like a slight change in heart rate,
a little shortness of breath.
They're again, they spiral.
Right, because they are terrified
of having another panic attack.
The target of the fear is the fear itself.
What's fascinating here is how the diagnostic criteria
force the clinician to look right past
the presenting symptom.
Because treating the symptom isn't enough.
No, you can't just treat the avoidance.
You have to treat the specific fear
that's actually driving it.
That makes total sense.
And it seems like the stakes for finding
that underlying engine get incredibly high
when we move from anxiety over to mood disorders.
Oh, absolutely.
Especially that boundary between unipolar-depressive
like major depressive disorder and bipolar disorder.
The source material made a huge deal out of this.
It is a matter of absolute critical safety.
I mean, when a client comes into a clinic,
they're almost always coming in
during the low, the depressive phase.
Right.
Think about it.
Nobody schedules an emergency therapy appointment
because they feel invincible, need zero sleep
and have this rush of brilliant racing thoughts.
Yeah, they only come in when they crash.
So they sit down on the couch
and they present looking exactly like someone
with standard major depressive disorder.
But here's the danger.
If you just look at that presentation
and you assume it's unipolar depression
and then treat it with a standard SSRI antidepressant,
you can cause profound harm.
Because SSRI's flood the brain with serotonin, right?
So if they actually have an underlying bipolar disorder
that you missed, what actually happens?
It acts like pouring rocket fuel onto a latent engine.
Oh my God.
Yeah, an antidepressant given alone
to someone with bipolar disorder
can literally flip that patient
into a full dangerous manic episode.
That is terrifying.
It really is.
They go from being profoundly depressed
to dangerously impulsive, detached from reality
or unable to sleep for days.
So just by giving them the standard treatment,
you make it worse.
Much worse.
It is the single most consequential danger
of misreading mood.
You treat the symptom directly in front of you
without checking the history
and you trigger a major crisis.
Wow.
That is why the cardinal rule in diagnostics
is that you must actively hunt
for a history of mania or hypomania
with every single depressed client.
You have to know the history
before you touch the chemistry.
Well said.
Which actually transitions us perfectly
to another boundary that really trips people up time.
The way timelines dictate
whether someone is detached from reality.
Yes, the psychotic spectrum.
Right.
When it comes to the psychotic spectrum,
it seems like the diagnosis is literally just a clock.
It is entirely built on duration.
It's like a ladder constructed out of time.
But why?
Why does the diagnostic system
care so much about a calendar?
Like let me walk up this ladder first.
If someone has psychotic symptoms, delusions,
hallucinations, maybe disorganized speech.
Right.
But they last under one month
and then the person returns to normal,
that's brief psychotic disorder.
Correct.
Then if it lasts between one and six months,
it's schizophrenia form disorder.
And if it crosses that six month mark,
it becomes schizophrenia.
What is magically happening at month six?
It's not magic, it's neurobiology and prognosis.
Okay, how so?
Well, the brain can experience brief psychotic breaks
due to immense acute stress or trauma.
Like a person might completely detach from reality
for two weeks under severe duress.
Just totally break from reality.
Yes, but once the stressor resolves,
their brain returns to baseline.
That's a temporary malfunction.
But as those symptoms stretch past six months,
we're no longer looking
at a temporary stress induced break.
What are we looking at then?
We're looking at an insidious,
pervasive neural cognitive change.
The six month threshold is the boundary
where clinicians have to recognize
that this is a lifelong management issue,
not just a passing storm.
Okay, that makes sense.
But what about when psychosis overlaps with a mood disorder?
Like when someone is deeply depressed
but also having delusions,
the manual gets really specific there too.
It does.
That's where the clinician has to look very closely
at the timeline again
to diagnose schizoaffective disorder.
Schizoaffective, yeah.
There must be a period of at least two weeks
where the psychosis is present completely on its own
without a major mood episode running alongside it.
Wait, so the psychosis basically has to stand
on its own two feet for a couple of weeks
to prove it's a separate entity
rather than just being
like a really severe feature of the depression.
Exactly, that freestanding stretch
of altered reality is the separator.
It proves the psychotic engine can run independently.
Okay, so we have timelines for reality.
But what about when people are detached from others?
The way personality styles are categorized is wild to me.
It's very nuanced.
Let's take someone who is just a total loner.
If you're at a party
and you see someone standing entirely alone in the corner
just staring at the wall, ignoring everyone,
that's schizoid personality disorder, right?
Like they just wanna be left alone.
Not necessarily.
You're looking at the behavior again
but missing the motive.
They could actually have avoidant personality disorder.
Wait, so if they're avoidant,
they are terrified of being judged.
If they're schizoid,
they just genuinely don't care about interacting.
It's all about the hidden motive.
Exactly right.
A person with schizoid personality disorder
genuinely prefers solitude.
They have a restricted range of emotional expression.
They simply don't desire close relationships.
So they're perfectly fine in that corner.
Yes, they are content there.
But the avoidant person who was also socially isolated
desperately wants connection.
Wow, that is so sad.
So why are they in the corner?
Because they are completely paralyzed
by the fear of rejection and inadequacy.
They're standing there agonizing,
wishing they could join the conversation
but terrified they'll be judged.
Those are two entirely different internal worlds.
Right, and imagine the harm
if a clinician gets that wrong.
If you try to push a schizoid client
into social exposure therapy,
treating them like they're avoidant.
They'd totally push them away.
You would completely alienate them.
You'd be trying to cure a fear they don't even have
to fulfill a desire they don't feel.
That makes so much sense.
Motive is literally everything.
And does motive separate the erratic,
highly emotional personalities too?
Because I know borderline personality disorder
and bipolar disorder get confused constantly.
All the time.
Yeah, because they both feature
these massive, intense mood swings.
They do, but again,
the separator is the tempo and the trigger.
Tempo and trigger, okay.
Borderline mood shifts are highly reactive.
They can happen in minutes or hours
and they are almost always triggered
by an interpersonal event.
Like what?
Specifically a perceived relationship rupture
or an intense fear of abandonment.
So if a friend doesn't text back,
someone with borderline might spiral
into intense anger or despair within an hour
just because that underlying fear of abandonment
was triggered.
But bipolar doesn't work like that.
Exactly.
Bipolar mood shifts are neurochemical events
that last for days, weeks, or even months.
They have a completely different tempo.
Right.
And they don't require an interpersonal trigger to start.
A manic episode can begin
regardless of whether your friend texted you back or not.
Got it.
Since we are talking about motives
and how things feel internally,
I wanna bring up the distinction between OCD and OCPD.
This really caught my attention in the prep materials.
I honestly always thought they were just variations
of the exact same thing.
Oh, they sound similar,
but the internal experience is night and day.
It really comes down to whether the symptoms
are egotistonic or egosyntonic.
Right, okay, let me see if I have this.
So OCD, obsessive compulsive disorder is egodistonic,
meaning the intrusive thoughts are totally unwanted,
the person hates them.
Yes.
So if they have an obsession that their house
will burn down, they are miserable,
and they perform compulsions like checking the stove
20 times just to neutralize that horrible anxiety.
Precisely.
The disorder is an unwelcome intruder in their mind,
but OCPD excessive compulsive personality disorder
is egosyntonic.
Which means it feels right to them.
Yes, it's a pervasive, rigid personality style
of perfectionism and control
that actually feels correct to the person.
So the person with OCPD who organizes their pantry
alphabetically and demands everyone in the house
follow these strict arbitrary rules,
they don't feel distressed about the rules themselves.
No, they feel distressed
when other people don't follow their rules.
Ah.
They believe their way is the objectively
correct way to live.
There were no unwanted intrusive obsessions,
no neutralizing compulsions,
just this deeply ingrained need for control.
Wow, okay.
Let's shift gears from the architecture of the mind
to how distress actually manifests in the physical body.
Because trauma, coping mechanisms, physical symptoms,
they all have their own strict boundaries.
They really do.
Let's start with the trauma timeline.
We saw the clock with psychosis earlier
and it turns out it dictates trauma diagnoses too.
Yes, because after a severe trauma,
we actually expect an acute psychological
and physical reaction.
Right, it's normal.
It is entirely normal for the body's alarm system
to be ringing.
So for the first three days after a trauma,
there is technically no disorder diagnosed.
It's just a normative human reaction.
And then from three days to one month,
it is classified as acute stress disorder.
Correct.
The brain is still in the immediate aftermath,
just trying to process the event.
And PTSD, post-traumatic stress disorder
is only diagnosed after that one month mark has passed.
Like if the symptoms of hypervigilance,
flashbacks and avoidance persist past day 30,
the label shifts.
Exactly.
But what if the stressor isn't a life-threatening trauma?
What if someone goes through a really brutal divorce
or they lose their job
and they are struggling physically and emotionally
way more than you'd expect?
That boundary is captured by adjustment disorder.
It's the disproportionate residual response
to a major life stressor
that doesn't quite meet the criteria for a severe trauma.
But sometimes, you know,
people try to cope with these stressors using substances.
And here's where it gets really interesting.
Oh, the substance guidelines.
Yeah.
This part honestly blew me away.
Hold on.
Based on every movie I've ever seen,
I thought opioid withdrawal
was the ultimate medical emergency.
The sweating, the shaking, the pure agony.
It looks like a life or death crisis on screen.
Right.
Hollywood loves to show that.
But you're telling me, based on this manual,
that alcohol withdrawal is the one that can actually be fatal
and requires benzodiazepine.
It is entirely counterintuitive.
Opioid withdrawal is genuinely miserable.
The physical pain, the nausea, the autonomic distress.
I mean, it is horrific to experience,
but it is very rarely fatal.
Wow.
On the other hand,
alcohol and sedative withdrawal can literally kill you.
Wait, alcohol withdrawal is the fatal one, but why?
Because of the physiological mechanism.
Alcohol and sedatives
are profound central nervous system depressants.
Over time, the brain constantly pumps out
excitatory chemicals just to keep you awake
and functioning against the heavy suppression of the alcohol.
Oh, I see.
So the brain is pressing the gas pedal to the floor
just to counter the breaks of the alcohol.
Exactly.
So what happens when you abruptly stop drinking?
The breaks are gone.
The breaks are suddenly gone.
But the brain is still flooring the gas pedal.
The central nervous system, essentially short circuits.
This massive over excitation leads to severe seizures
and a condition called delirium tremens,
which involves profound confusion, hallucinations
and cardiovascular collapse.
Meaning medical safety absolutely overrides
any psychological intervention in those moments.
You can't do talk therapy when the brain is seizing.
No, you cannot.
It requires medical management, usually with benzos,
to just taper that excitation down.
If we connect this to the bigger picture,
society often judges substances based on legality or stigma.
But clinical diagnostics is purely
about physiological reality.
Yeah, its body doesn't care about the law.
No, it doesn't.
And speaking of physiological reality,
the manual draws a very specific boundary
around addictions.
Gambling disorder is the only behavioral addiction
officially recognized.
Wait, not video games, not social media.
I hear people call themselves
addictions to those all the time.
Not formally, no.
Because the clinical evidence shows
the gambling hijacks the exact same
neural reward circuitry as chemical substances.
The dopamine surge, the tolerance,
the severe withdrawal-like cravings,
it perfectly mimics substance use
without a chemical ever entering the bloodstream.
That is wild.
But I guess the physical manifestations of mental health
are probably most stark when we look at eating disorders.
The notes mention anorexia nervosa
has the highest mortality rate
of any disorder in psychiatry.
The highest, period.
The severe caloric restriction
doesn't just cause weight loss,
it degrades the heart muscle,
leading to fatal arrhythmias.
Oh, wow.
This is why, just like with severe alcohol withdrawal,
medical stabilization must precede psychological treatment.
You have to stabilize the heart
before you explore the mind.
That makes sense.
And the boundary between anorexia and bulimia
is heavily dependent on weight, right?
Yes, anorexia involves significantly low body weight.
A person with bulimia engages in binge eating
and compensatory behaviors like purging,
but they maintain a normal
or even above normal body weight.
But there's another eating disorder we need to talk about
that strips away the body image component entirely, ARFI.
Avoidant Restrictive Food Intake Disorder.
ARFID is fascinating
because it involves severe, dangerous food restriction
that leads to profound nutritional deficiency,
but there is absolutely no fear of gaining weight.
None. None. Yeah.
There was no body image distortion.
So why are they starving?
It's often driven by intense sensory aversions.
So the texture, the smell, the color of the food
is just unbearable to them.
Or it's driven by an intense phobia
of choking or vomiting.
Oh, I see.
Again, if a clinician assumes
all food restriction is driven by a fear of fatness,
they will completely misdiagnose and mistreat
the ARFID client.
Okay, so we've covered the hidden motives,
the internal clocks, the body's response.
Let's scale this out across a person's lifespan
and look at the real-world ethical stakes
for the people doing the diagnosing.
Let's start with childhood, ADHD.
A very common one.
Right.
The diagnostic criteria require
that the symptoms of inattention or hyperactivity
appear before age 12,
and crucially, they must be present
in two or more settings.
Why is that multiple setting rule so important?
Because ADHD is a neurodevelopmental disorder.
It is a structural and functional difference
in how the brain operates.
And a brain doesn't completely change how it operates
just because you walk through a different door.
Ah, okay.
So if a kid is heavily distracted and impulsive at school
but perfectly focused, organized, and calm at home.
Then you likely don't have a neurodevelopmental disorder.
What do you have then?
You might have a kid who is being bullied
or has a learning disability specific to that classroom
or is dealing with anxiety triggered
by that specific teacher.
If the symptoms don't exist in two settings,
you have to look at the environment,
not just the child's brain.
That is such a crucial distinction.
And jumping to the other end of the lifespan,
the distinction between delirium and dementia
in older adults is another major safety boundary.
Dementia, like Alzheimer's, is insidious.
It creeps in slowly over years
and progressively degrades cognition.
But delirium is acute.
Yes, delirium comes on rapidly over hours or days
and cognition severely fluctuates.
And the key here is the mechanism.
Delirium is usually caused
by a reversible underlying medical issue.
Like what kind of issue?
Well, in elderly patients,
a simple urinary tract infection
or a bad reaction to a new medication
can cause sudden profound confusion and hallucinations
that look terrifyingly like severe dementia.
But if a clinician or a doctor mistakes
that sudden delirium for a natural progressive decline,
they might just shrug and say,
well, they're getting older.
And they miss the chance to cure it
with a simple course of antibiotics.
Delirium is a medical emergency
hiding as cognitive decline.
The theme of crisis and safety
is just everywhere in this framework.
Let's talk about assessing suicide risk.
When a clinician is sitting with someone in crisis,
they use structured protocols
like the Columbia Suicide Severity Rating Scale.
The CSSRS, yes.
Right, they assess the ideation, the plan,
the intent, the access to lethal means.
But I was really surprised by what the standard is
for actually preventing it.
Because for decades, you know,
we've heard about no suicide contracts.
You make the patient sign a paper
promising they won't hurt themselves.
And those contracts are not evidence-based.
In fact, they can be deeply harmful.
Why though, wouldn't a promise help?
Because a contract is coercive.
It exists primarily to protect the clinician's liability,
not to empower the patient.
It essentially tells the patient,
promise you won't do this, or else.
The evidence-based standard is a collaborative safety plan.
A safety plan, where they sit down together
and map out a step-by-step strategy
for what the patient can actually do when a crisis hits.
Yes.
It sounds more like, when the pain hits an eight out of 10,
I will call this friend.
If they don't answer, I will try this coping skill.
If that fails, I will call this hotline.
So it's actionable.
Exactly.
It gives the patient agency and concrete tools
rather than a coercive demand.
The framework also carefully separates suicidal intent
from non-suicidal self-injury, or an SSI.
When someone is cutting or burning themselves,
it's natural for people to panic
and assume it's a suicide attempt.
But NSSI has a completely different function.
The function of NSSI is almost always a motion regulation.
It is a deeply maladaptive physical way
to deal with unbearable emotional numbness
or overwhelming distress.
So it's not about dying?
No.
The physical pain is used to ground the person
or release internal pressure.
It is not an attempt to end a life.
You have to assess the function of the behavior
rather than just panicking
and immediately hospitalizing someone,
which honestly could traumatize them further.
Which leads right into the ethical rules
of engagement for clinicians.
Confidentiality is the absolute bedrock of therapy.
It has to be.
But it has hard limits.
The Terasov Duty is the most famous one.
The duty to warn and protect.
Right.
If a client makes a specific credible threat
of imminent violence against a specific identifiable victim,
the clinician is legally and ethically bound
to break confidentiality to warn that victim
and notify the police.
But it has to be a specific threat, right?
Like the clinician can't break confidentiality
just because a client is vaguely venting saying,
oh, I hate my boss.
I wish you were dead.
Correct.
Vague venting is not actionable.
The threat must be imminent and targeted.
And similar, very strict thresholds apply
to mandated reporting of child or elder abuse.
For mandated reporting,
the threshold is reasonable suspicion, not concrete proof.
The rule is basically you report, you do not investigate.
Let me try an analogy here.
Let's hear it.
So mandated reporting is like smelling smoke coming
from under a locked door.
My job is just to pull the fire alarm and wait outside.
If I kick open the door to investigate the fire myself
to gather evidence, I'm actually doing the wrong job
and wasting precious time.
That is an excellent way to conceptualize it.
You are not a detective.
If you delay protection to play investigator,
you risk the child's safety and you fail ethically.
But the nuance is in the word reasonable.
You don't pull the fire alarm just
because someone mentions the word fire.
Right, you have to assess.
You assess the situation, apply the code,
consult with the supervisor
and document every single step of your reasoning.
The measured answer is always the right one in ethics.
Okay, we've covered the engines of fear,
the timelines of reality, physical emergencies
and ethical crises.
How does a clinician capture all of this complexity
in real time?
The tool they use is called the mental status exam
or MSE, right?
Yes, the MSE is the ultimate clinical photograph.
It is a structured observation of exactly
how the client presents in the room
during that specific session.
It is not their history, it is the now.
And the MSE features a few distinctions
that are famously tricky.
First is mood versus affect.
I love the way this is conceptualized in the source.
Mood is the climate and affect is the weather.
That's a perfect shared shorthand.
Mood is subjective.
It is the overall climate the client tells you
they're experiencing.
I have been profoundly depressed for weeks.
But the affect is the weather outside the window right now.
It's subjective, it's the emotional expression
the clinician observes in the room.
Right, and you are watching for incongruence.
If a client tells you their climate is devastatingly sad
but their affect is a bright smiling,
laughing presentation while they discuss trauma.
That mismatch is highly clinically significant.
That's fascinating.
The other big distinction in the MSE
is thought process versus thought content.
Process is the form or the shape of the thinking.
Is it linear?
Is it racing so fast they can't breathe?
Or is it totally disorganized like a word salad?
In content is the actual substance of the words.
It's what they are thinking about.
The delusions, the obsessions, the suicidal ideation.
So you have to track both simultaneously.
This raises an important question.
The mental status exam requires the clinician
to hold two realities at once.
What the client is saying
and how the client is fundamentally operating in space.
It ensures they don't miss the truth
hidden behind the symptoms.
So what does this all mean?
It's the ultimate test of paying attention
and that really brings us full circle
because everything we've talked about today
proves that being well informed about mental health
isn't just about memorizing symptom lists.
Not at all.
It's about paying incredibly close attention
to context, to time, to the invisible targets of fear
and to those hidden motives.
But as we wrap up, I want to leave you listening at home
with one final thought to mull over.
We talked about how our current diagnostic system
is heavily, almost rigidly reliant on timelines.
Exactly one month to cross the boundary
from acute stress to PTSD.
Exactly six months to shift
from schizophrenia to schizophrenia.
But what happens to the person
who is suffering profoundly on day 29 or on day 179?
Does the human brain actually know what day it is?
As we learn more about neurobiology,
will the future of psychology
eventually abandon these strict calendar-based labels
entirely, moving toward a system
that treats the individual engine of distress
regardless of what the clock says?
It's something to explore on your own.
That's a profound question.
We started out talking about the messy, murky reality
of diagnosing the human mind
where the X-ray machine is broken
and all the boundaries are drawn in gray.
But hopefully today's deep dive gave you a glimpse
into exactly how professionals find clarity
inside all that complexity.
Thank you for joining us and stay curious.